IMDb oddly has a lot of popular negative
reviews for House of the Dragon so I
thought it would be fun to quickly look
through some and by quickly I'll
probably just look at a few ridiculous
lines from each review because reading
all of them will take a long time I'm
also sorting by a featured so it's not
like I'm scouring the bottom depths of
the IMDb reviewing landscape and there
seems to be a lot of people agreeing
with these reviews 5 out of 10 expensive
soap opera it carries the vibe of one of
those cheap British soap operas only
without the drama weak acting doll
dialogue in poor Direction at such a low
blow to house the dragon holy crap I
like how they say without the drama as
if there's like utterly no conflict
within the entirety of the show along
with them saying there's a weak acting
like visceros Targaryen I mean just
recently Emma DRC got nominated for an
award in the Golden Globes and doll
dialogue it's better than most shows the
original show also started slow but soon
found his footing after a few episodes
particularly with the death of Ned Stark
so let's unpack there but I mean he dies
on episode nine not after the first few
episodes The Sarah Targaryen dies by
episode 8 and that was such a great
payoff moment for his entire character
Arc so I would say the least the show
found its footing by that point as the
point of comparison this guy thinks that
the book of Boba Fett is the same
quality of House of the Dragon 4 out of
10. the dragons looked great the crew in
charge of lighting must have gone on
strike cause most of the Season played
out in semi-darkness one moment out of
the entirety of the show this is like a
very big nitpack and it also seemed like
most of the episode had a plot for about
30 minutes of time which caused scenes
to be dragged out painfully I guess this
person's version of scenes dragging out
is characters talking to each other I
don't think he realizes that that's a
necessity when it comes to Bringing
characters to life in Supply applied
with fillers like 10 minutes of soft
porn in episode 4. this is a part of
Damon and Rainier's Journey it's like
their romance and their like younger
years and 10 minutes of people dancing
in episode 5. I highly doubt there's
just flat out 10 minutes of people
dancing I'm sure that's an exaggeration
as for the acting I'm not gonna comment
on that since the lack of character
build gave the actors very little to
work with I mean there was a lot of
character building this person
simultaneously saying that their scenes
are dragged out painfully with very
little plot which would indicate that
there would be a lot of character
building but then he simultaneously
saying that there is no character
building for the actors to work with 6
out of ten none of these characters have
deep substance to me viserys between the
two shows has one of the deepest arcs
and most of the time we're just like
unpacking the emotional baggage that
bernera has to go through six out of ten
where's the political Intrigue where's
the conflict collect a plot centered
around a daughter's refusal to marry
such being a female Heir is not
interesting enough to be the sole plot
for four episodes there needs to be
additional conflicts I mean if there was
even more conflict within this season
that would be pretty freaking packed
like every character has a lot of [ __ ]
they have to deal with and this guy is
definitely exaggerating where obviously
the first four episodes don't just deal
with the sole plot of Vernier having to
marry slash being a female Heir what
about when you're losing her mother
faceris having to move on very quickly
which makes it seem like he didn't
really care about renira's mother all of
her lust boiling over for the people she
actually wants to love but can't her
obligations to the throne on top of
having to marry and so many other
aspects and this all happens in like
four episodes and this person wants to
throw in even more conflict into this
boiling over pots of chaos it just may
not have an overly engaging plot with a
bunch of plot twists and complex
storylines that people seem to think
that if a show doesn't have that then
it's bad 3 out of 10 a high budget
glorified soap opera the first five
episodes could have been packaged into
one or two episodes I like how the last
person was just like we need more
conflict and this person's like combined
everything you know how chaotic that
would be if he thinks that nothing
happened in those five episodes and he's
delusional the acting is really subpar
for the hype there is no chemistry
whatsoever I mean Matt Smith has
chemistry with literally anyone the show
has reached the mid-season and I failed
to see the direction of the storyline on
one hand you have a bunch of people
complaining about that's not complex
enough but this person's failing to see
the direction I thought it was supposed
to be too simple it's a meaningless soap
opera why is everyone saying this is any
form of drama just a soap opera nowadays
4 out of 10. casting was a disaster it
seems not confident to go with new
actors not bold enough to put money down
for great known actors casting was
outstanding I loved all of the
characters and I they were fully
realized by the actors that were
portraying them and they did go with new
actors like both of the actors
portraying granera were pretty much new
same thing with young Allison's and then
not pulled enough to put money down for
great known actors like I think Matt
Smith is pretty well known at this point
like if anything I'd kind of argue that
he's just as popular as Sean Bean was
given that he's been in Doctor Who in
morbius it's a mixed bag along with a
delivery of lines and the scenes in
general come across very flat and
uninteresting people keep calling this
uninteresting do they just want more
action they came to the dragon show but
wanted more dragons I guess for some
reason the show Blows Its load in the
first minute by having a dragonfly
around the place with a rider on it this
person clearly hasn't seen the rest of
the show because that clearly was not
the show blowing its load no character
development no characters that are
relatable or likable I wonder what was
happening the entire 10 hours did these
people just like watch these shows with
like a blank expression as like they
start drooling thinking that nothing's
happening just like dopamine fires in
their brains and the dragon shows up and
they start clapping hey there it is 4
out of 10 a boring soap opera 4 out of
10. despite half-hearted efforts a shock
with sex and violence I guess this
person must have hated Game of Thrones
because there's a lot more nudity in sex
in Game of Thrones than there is in
House of the Dragon tries to put a
shoddy girl power veneer all right I'm
just gonna stop there three out of ten
the casting went so wrong neither the
characters nor the actors are likable
damn I didn't know people hated the cast
this much two out of ten the characters
are one-dimensional and there is no
chemistry ah this is sounding very
familiar the special effects are
laughable compared to what got was able
to pull off even in its first season
I'll be obviously this guy's grasping at
straws that just don't exist just boring
conversation after boring conversation
I've had to take breaks every 20 minutes
they're purely allergic to any dialogue
despite Game of Thrones having tons of
it 3 out of ten four episodes in it is
as dull as dishwasher amateur night
wannabe I don't even know what that
means and I can't even attempt to unpack
what it means the main characters are an
interesting and Bland a common complaint
it seems whilst the dialogue is about as
incisive as a feather duster at least
this guy is being creative with his
insults 4 out of 10. after all the hype
they present us with long very boring
discussions and dreary Exposition I mean
there really isn't that much Exposition
if you think about it no action no
excitement just talk talk I think this
guy is outing himself as an action
fanatic which again I don't know how he
survived Game of Thrones young Millie
struggles to enunciate her lines what
dragons are so yesterday and these are
not the best CGI we've seen by any means
do they want to just replace dragons
with [ __ ] unicorns one out of ten I
am very surprised at the positive
reviews and can only think they are fake
or misguided the classic take of if
people disagree with me they're
obviously not true 2 out of ten a very
very very bad decision to change the
lead actors disappointed hugely I mean
the new ones were good too do they want
like Millie to play a 30 to 40 year old
woman one out of ten four episodes and
it's nothing but a slow and boring soap
opera with some soft porn what the
traditional got violence and moronic
dialogue I wish they would bring up
examples for the moronic dialogue and
there's really not much violence in the
house of the Dragon people are just
talking to each other oh no they're
talking four out of ten Greed for
casting is a d plus casting reflects the
latest Hollywood tiresome Obsession
racial quotas and affirmative action
type casting is this guy really that mad
that they made Corliss for larion and
the other valerians black because it it
really wasn't that big of a deal on the
show I like how at the bottom he says
House of the Dragon deserves a rating of
about six or seven I rated it four
because the inflated ratings of 10 skew
the results I'm very glad that we have
integrity for reviewing one out of ten
waiting all week for one episode is such
a letdown in the days of Netflix this
guy's purely just very spoiled all the
episodes besides the first have been
such a snooze Fest they want battle the
bastards every other episode no one is
watching the show for your sorry attempt
to direct porn like House of dragon had
like three sex scenes which pales in
comparison to the nudity in season one
like within the first three episodes it
already has more than that so yeah I
think that's enough for now there's also
surprisingly a lot more of these reviews
so I can easily do another one of these
videos if it does well regardless though
thank you for watching and I guess we
can discuss further in the comments
about what these people were saying